on august 8th
2020 the season 2 finale of rise of the
mewdy tooty sneak boys aired
and as of now it seems like this might
be the series finale
as nickelodeon ordered the second season
be cut short the series ends on a
heartfelt finale where the turtles
battle the shredder one final time with
their classic weapons
a little bit of magic and most
importantly the power of family
there are some genuinely sweet and
emotional moments to punctuate the final
deadly encounter that perfectly
encapsulated
everything this show was good at leaving
us with only 13 episodes of this season
instead of the planned 26
the series creator andy suriano posted
to his instagram a long and heartfelt
goodbye to the show that makes it pretty
clear
it's not looking good for the future of
the series much like many classic
superhero cartoons before it
ryze was controversial among the fandom
for doing things differently
in andy's unfortunately depressing note
he even says they went out of their way
to make sure the characters
and the show itself weren't easily
categorized and strive to be more
complicated than the usual box this
franchise would be put in
thinking outside the box is often a
risky move for big name franchise series
such as this
but i want to extend my hand to the
creators and the fans in asking you to
hear me break down
what was so impressive and special about
this series
and maybe seeing why it deserves to live
again
rise of the title that's too long is the
fourth animated series based on the
teenage mutant action figure salesman
a comic book with hilarious and
irreverent disdain for the 80s era of
comics despite being one of the most
memorable examples of them
essential of the tortugas is a show i
thought i would hate when i saw the
first promotional images because i've
been burned by a lot of modern cartoons
lately
between the cheaply animated and
underwritten exploits of spider-me
or the pointless yet admittedly pretty
funny ongoing adventures of the never
getting a season six gang
i didn't have high hopes i thought this
was going to be another poorly animated
show about nothing where the episodes
are just
the turtles twerking and making
sandwiches with little to no action i
have
never been happier to be wrong sure this
show's emphasis
is on silly character-driven tomfoolery
with a superhero spin
but it manages to do that with a subtle
nuance and an insane sense of style that
few other superhero cartoons have right
now
i'd argue that given the state of things
this is probably the best comic book
cartoon
out there at the moment by a thousand
miles it's not even close
where these other shows trip and fall on
their face or make it clear they don't
really care about participating in the
race at all
this show barry allen's its ass off back
around the track so fast your head spins
yet i haven't seen much praise for it
anywhere
and i get the sense that a lot of people
hate it because it's not a direct
regurgitation of the shows that came
before it
the typical bad faith criticism which
seems to be a recurring theme for
superhero cartoons
what else could this show have been if
not something very different
think of it like this you've got this
80s action comic that's a clever parody
and subversion of frank miller's style
of comics with a memorable premise
it's dark and violent and weird and
awesome
so there's this adaptation that waters
it down into something kitty and dumb
for the mainstream
instant classic beloved by millions
there's not a ton of continuity every
episode is a lighthearted self-contained
adventure with a somewhat limited but
very entertaining cast of villains the
silly fun
madhouse show then you have the reboot
cartoon that pulls a risky move by
adapting the weirdo crazy comic almost
word for word in many cases and despite
its lack of blood is
decently mature in subject matter and
tone while still feeling accommodating
to the fans of the 80s cartoon
characters are a little on the weaker
side but it has great long-running story
development and overarching
multi-episode plots
the darker but still fun plot-driven
show
then the third show that tries to meld
the previous two together with varying
levels of success
it tries to have its cake and eat it too
with pacing that jumps between
self-contained episodes and
long-running episodic plots but for the
most part it's enjoyable for being a
nostalgic love letter to the 80s cartoon
with a fresh coat of paint and a more
developed and mature spin on its
characters
the nostalgic character-driven show well
what did you just want him to make one
of these again all of these shows had
episode counts in the triple digits and
ran for over five years each
you can't just keep going with one of
these exactly as they were
or it would get boring there's a reason
all of these got lower ratings in their
final seasons and started to lose their
audience
they got stale and needed a fresh new
makeover this show
needed to be something different there's
a lot of ways to look at the material
and we've already had two of the more
serious takes in a row
so we felt due for a lighter toned
turtle show
and aside from being less about the
overall plot and more about just having
fun
really doesn't have that much in common
with the 80s show either
this show doesn't excel by retreading
old ground and doing it better
its success is found in all the things
that make it unique
it uses a more mystical spin to offset
2012's heavily sci-fi aesthetic
it remixes the characters to break out
of their typical molds
and its visual style is incredibly fresh
and unique
just like what mr siriano said in his
obituary for the show
let me break down for you dear viewer
why this show is different
and why that makes it such a blast
ryze has less serial more episodic
stories but it doesn't frustrate me like
the 2012 show because it doesn't over
promise anything else yes the story
moves forward an inch at a time over the
course of the
26 episodes in the first season but rise
of the middle aged orphan bats makes it
clear that the main goal of the show
isn't to tell an overarching plot it's
very upfront with the fact that this is
a series of one-off adventures
most of which can be told in any order
by comparison the 2012 show
bugged me because it couldn't decide
between one-off stories and a long arc
so it tried to do both and became
irritating to binge watch because of the
repetitive nature of the stories
rise doesn't really have that problem
because it's not throwing plot into the
background of every single episode
it creeps in every four or five episodes
where they do one that advances the
story and gives us a bigger idea of
what's going on
it's easier to manage my expectations
for the story then because i know i'm
not supposed to be on the edge of my
seat wondering what's gonna happen with
these villains every five minutes
i can just relax and enjoy the ride of
an episode where they return a light dvd
and get attacked by a super villain
or go on an adventure fighting an evil
robot in a pizza restaurant
and like i said it's never repetitive
while binge watching
because the show always finds something
new and fun to do with its own
established world and characters
the general plot of the first season is
that between all the low stakes high
energy fun
these two magical criminals with the
foot clan logo on their faces are trying
to find
the pieces of a cursed suit of armor and
once it's fully reformed it will
resurrect their master the shredder
you're also occasionally teaming up with
a demon named john c
baron draxum who wants to use magic
alchemy to perform twisted experiments
on humans and mutate them into what he
believes is a superior race
13 years ago the fallout of this guy's
experiments accidentally mutated the
turtles by splicing them with the human
dna of the man splinter once was
all of their human traits come from him
meaning in this show splinter is
biologically their father instead of
just their adopted one
i may think the iron dad craze is cringy
as all hell but my cold black heart
expels some dust when the turtles call
splinter their dad in any cannon
we check back in on this plot every few
episodes and spend most of our time
focusing on the down time between
it doesn't drag as much as you'd think
because they aren't dangling shredder's
return and the subplot of the armor in
your face
every single episode and they know how
to space it out properly so you can
enjoy the smaller stuff in the meantime
and even during the low stakes minor
league outings against random mutants
and monsters
we get something pretty unexpected some
damn
fine character work especially for two
of my favorite members of any turtles
cast
well leo since you sell the fewest
action figures why don't you go ahead
and jump first
ignoring that something to appreciate
this show for
is that despite the plot's backburner
approach there's always some very subtle
development happening for one or two of
the characters in the background of the
highly animated chaos
and when the story finally kicks in all
that development during the hijinx
plays into the story and makes it so
much more satisfying and impactful
leonardo's development as leader is slow
and subtle
and very different from the other shows
well a lot of the time
leo is just the leader at the start and
you have to accept it
the 2012 show gave us a little insight
into his desire to lead and his
aspiration to be the one
on the front of the box we saw him
slowly earn his status through trial and
error and that made it more satisfying
he seemed less like a hard-shelled
authority figure and more like an
underdog that we rooted for
rise gives us a clever subversion of
this by having raphael
start as the leader and clearly not be
that great at it
like he's fine but his ratio of wins to
losses is so far in the red it looks
like his bandana
meanwhile leo's like the easy-going
chill guy that sort of along for the
ride and when the time comes that raft's
leadership
fails leo steps up from the background
and shows how it's really done
he doesn't aspire to be the leader at
all he never challenges raph's position
and
just hangs out but we see many glimpses
into the fact that he's just naturally
the best choice for the leader
and i dig how quietly they build this up
over both seasons
oh then blue you are the leader now wait
what
splinter is probably the farthest
departure from his usual self
every version of splinters so far is
pretty much the same personality wise
but this guy's got some subtle new
complexity
initially he seems like a grouchy sack
of rat that just lays around all day and
makes fun of the turtles
hey pop any chance we could have the
living room tonight
and i thought purple was the funny one i
told you guys i was the funniest
pretty lame and i get why the reaction
was so volatile
but it turns out he's got more going on
as you watch the series
he's trained them through a mr miyagi
method of doing it without them
knowing it the turtles spend all day
watching and replicating fight moves
from an old jackie chan style martial
arts actor named
lujitsu and splinter has trained them to
idolize this guy in a way that they
don't for him
they see splinter as their grouchy
father but they see lujitsu as a hero
and an inspiration for mastering the
ways of the ninja
he makes them watch movies of lou
fighting guys with dead fish and step
ladders and they start to think it's
never going to be relevant
until the day they find themselves with
no weapons except
and you get the rest his teaching is
subtle and indirect but he still gave
them the tools to survive some pretty
crazy circumstances
beyond that splinter's greatest secret
is that he's not only the mutated hamato
yoshi
he is lujitsu the martial arts master
and movie star
after being mutated his body let itself
go somewhat but his skills as a fighter
never
faded that's why it's so cool to finally
see him get out of the chair and teach
the boys a lesson when they
underestimate him in a fight
he's just as badass as ever upon
learning his human identity the kids all
discover a newfound respect for their
father
and start following his guidance more as
far as we're concerned we live with our
hero
tell us about that stunt man again oh
chad what a prankster
and as a result of that respect he's not
as afraid to teach them more directly
about responsibility
and reaches out to them emotionally we
see him becoming more active
as a teacher and as a parent even
participating in some of their
shenanigans too
there's character development happening
and i love the way this show reinvents
these characters and creates new arcs
for them
even raph donnie and mikey all have
little stories of growth along the way
like raph learning his place on the team
and trusting his brothers more
donny becoming more humble about his
intelligence and mikey having to be more
brave
they're still the characters we know and
love deep down below all the flash
we just get to see them evolving in new
ways that we didn't really get to see in
any of the previous series as the tmnt
are usually a bit more static in their
personalities
this isn't just booty shaking meme spout
and chaos
and while there's certainly an audience
for that and it isn't necessarily a bad
thing
i appreciate the hell out of ryze for
not falling into the pitfall of
just trying to emulate what's
financially successful right now
and outside of its deep characters and
fun tone it's got something going for it
that deserves all the praise it gets
and way more this show is by far
the most visually interesting tmnt
series
with its colorful and sharp character
designs its beautifully rendered
environments
and its emphasis on expressive fluid
high-energy movement
i think this is a beautiful blend of
western and eastern animation
because it also has some pretty strong
anime influence on its fight
choreography and some of its visual gags
i mentioned previously that the 2012
series felt limited by being a cgi
rendered show because
they couldn't model as many new
locations characters and environments as
a 2d show
and this one proves that right by having
zero limitations
the turtles feel like they can go
anywhere and
do anything and they do it with such
grace and style
i can't think of any animated show i've
seen that was this
ambitious with its visuals this is the
spider-verse of tv cartoons and i'm glad
nickelodeon never slashed this show's
absurdly high animation budget
some people chalk rise up to just being
pure eye candy with no substance but i
disagree
there's a lot going on that you have to
be paying attention to appreciate
underneath the slick visuals
i also can't get enough of this show's
sense of humor ah yes so in this case a
game of basketball
donny i know you know how to say it
we're all on to you
the dialogue doesn't quite have that
same stink of written by a 45 year old
white guy trying to sound like a
teenager
all the slang used by the characters
feels natural and appropriate
or ironic when necessary and i don't
find myself cringing at the more
contemporary gags and story ideas
there's a whole episode where the
turtles are trying to watch a skating
competition on their phones while
stopping a robbery and they're too bad
at multitasking to do both
not only is this a funny setup for a
fight scene but it feels pretty on brand
for today's teenagers while not coming
off as preachy about it
it's not the same phone bad video game
bad stuff you keep seeing in the modern
simpsons episodes
the green knight rises also goes out of
its way to create new and interesting
villains but make sure they still
feel like common tmnt foes a lot of
these guys seem so
natural that i was sure they'd be modern
takes on characters from previous
cartoons
but nope they're wholly original my
favorite is baron draxum
he has this slow redemption arc from a
demonic scientist who hates humans to an
eccentric guy who lives among them and
protects them
that's pretty special you don't see
shredder or krang pulling a 180 like
that
i'm just not sure who voices him because
all the behind the scenes footage shows
an empty seat in the recording booth and
as for shredder they spend two seasons
building him up as a genuine
threat and only giving a taste of his
power during his first two appearances
in the season finale you learn he's
actually pretty heavily inspired by
tengu shredder from the 2003 show once
he's gotten his mind back he's
everything you'd hoped for from shredder
i just wish we got to see more of them
your essence will soon be mined
and then i will be unstoppable
the show goes out of its way to really
take him seriously
and the episodes involving him tend to
either have the best action sequences by
far
or the most emotional and serious
moments of the show
i do have to mention things i don't like
about the show of course to keep it fair
but that's a pretty short list
i wish we had gotten to see this show's
take on casey jones since he's also one
of my absolute favorites in the turtle
mythos though it would be hard for them
to make him much different from the 2012
version
wait what which leads me to the next one
this is two shows in a row with
april as a high schooler and i kind of
miss her being an adult
more like a big sister to the turtles
rather than a friend of their own age
props for not making her kiss any of
them though that earns you a lot of
points in my book
and finally the backstory and history of
this hidden magic city filled with yokai
is sort of vague and unclear but a major
chunk of the characters cast
come from here and it would have been
nice to know more about it
like why humans drove the yokai
underground or how this society works or
who runs it
the only glimpses we see are typically
just leo and the boys messing around
with this magic skeleton guy who lives
down there
and occasionally seeing more about this
world through him or the demon spider
lady who runs a magic fight club in the
basement of her hotel
i was just curious about this stuff and
would have liked to know more about it
it left me wanting more which isn't a
bad thing but
it would have made the show a little
more satisfying that's the rub of pacing
out information with your show so
slowly you run the risk of leaving
questions unanswered if it gets abruptly
cancelled for stupid reasons
for whatever brainless reason almost
half of this show's episodes originally
aired at 9am on a saturday
can you remember ever being awake that
early when you were a kid
or like even as an adult i don't think a
lot of people would catch that
no one wants to get up early on saturday
that's the one day a week you're allowed
to sleep in as a reward for the previous
five days of eight to three or nine to
five boring garbage
well i mean when we all collectively
still went to school and work
even though it got better with season
two airing more in the evenings on
friday
the damage was still done it doesn't
help that the show is only really on
cable and it doesn't stream anywhere
my 11 year old sister is 13 now and she
doesn't watch basic cable
it's all youtube and streaming platforms
i don't even have cable at my house and
i just had to buy the entire season on
amazon to see this show officially and
support it
you couldn't have put the first season
on hulu or netflix or something
so nickelodeon pumped an insane amount
of money into this show's budget
but decided it was best to be airing
exclusively on a platform that young
people have effectively abandoned
and a lot of it was premiering at times
no one could see it what sense does that
make
gee that sure does sound familiar why
does this keep happening
i feel like as cable television recedes
and streaming grows
more and more kids shows are just going
to keep sharing this
fate if there's any target demographic
you have to really
chase after it's the younger kids
because if they don't have immediate
access to something
they won't go searching for it and will
just find something else
to watch rise of the tmnt was a show
worth watching
i know a lot of folks out there may have
been apprehensive because it's not what
they were used to
but all you had to do was give it a
chance to win you over with its good
qualities
and more than that rise is a show worth
saving
right now the only plans for any
continuation are a netflix based movie
coming out eventually
but that's not the seth rogen one that's
a different thing
nickelodeon has a habit of tying up
shows they cut short with a random movie
dumped on netflix because they don't
feel like showing it on the channel
well i say that's not gonna cut the
ninja robot here this show ended way too
soon and deserves a second chance look
unfortunately reviving a show like
spectacular spider-man or earth's
mightiest heroes is kind of a pipe dream
because those creators have all moved on
to new projects and are busy
while the brand has evolved and those
characters have new shows to fill out
the gap
not to mention all the licensing and
rights agreements you have to dance
around to revive those
but ninja turtles is owned exclusively
by viacom and they don't really have
that issue
and i'm willing to bet the show's
creators haven't had time to pack up
shop and move on just yet
they still have episodes storyboarded
and ready to go if they wanted to make
them
if there's any good time to push for
this show to get picked back
up it's now let your voice be heard make
a ton of noise on social media directed
at nick and viacom that you want this
show to come back
and be aired in a new way nick has
stated that they had plans to start
producing more content for netflix and
putting avatar back on there was a sign
of goodwill to get that rolling
this is exactly what they're looking for
this show should release on netflix and
get at least another three seasons
before netflix inevitably also cancels
it because they always do that and god
damn it i wanted to know what was gonna
happen on santa clarita diet
but there's still a shot for this one to
live on and get a second life if we just
push for it
i kind of don't know if they work but
start some petitions get a hashtag
trending
politely ask the right people
let's make a move hashtag save rise of
tmnt
and say no to meanpool this show is
definitely different but at the end of
the day it's still
understood the core themes of tmnt with
brotherhood
family and absurd adventures that aren't
afraid to be silly or insane
if you haven't watched it before it's
definitely worth your time
and if you have watched it there's no
doubt you probably want to see more
so let's not let this one end up like so
many others let's
save this show because we still love
being a turtle
i love it when having no plan comes
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Music]
you